madame la Présidente chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'État à l'enfance madame la
ministre vous avez annoncé le maintien
de la civise avec des missions élargies
à toute forme de violence faite aux
enfants les chires les chiffres qui
suivent sont
insupportables toutes les 3 minutes un
enfant est victime d'inceste ou de
violence 165000 enfants sont victimes
d'agression sexuelle à l'échelle d'une
classe
cela représente un enfant sur 5 80 % des
des agressions sont intrafilial et 50 %
des victimes disent ne pas avoir été
soutenu par leurs propres parents
pardonnez ma franchise mais ces chiffres
donnent envie de vomir madame la
Première ministre a lancé un plan contre
les violences envers les enfants passons
maintenant de la parole aux actes des
actes il en existe dans ma
circonscription du forê dans la Loire où
l'association espaceour our de Madame
lidie Pevel fait un travail remarquable
pour repérer des enfants victimes
d'agissement monstrueux espace a reçu
une subvention de 50000 € en 2022 que
vous avez supprimé en 2023 plongeant les
bénévoles dans un profond désarrois ma
question est simple l'association Espace
peut-elle de nouveau toucher cette
subvention pour continuer àouver des
enfants victimes d'inceste et de
violence bien merci beaucoup coup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Charlotte cobel ministre en charge de
l'enfance merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Jean-Pierre tête oui je vous
remercie pour votre question vous l'avez
dit madame la Première ministre a
présenté un plan de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles à l'occasion du
comité intermissel de l'enfance le 20
novembre dernier ce plan ambitieux est
accompagné de renforts de moyens humains
et financiers pour tous les acteurs de
la lutte contre ces violences dont vous
avez rappelé les chiffres un enfant sur
10 c'est déjà pas mal un adulte sur 10
c'est déjà pas mal mais en tout cas des
chiffres inacceptables y compris dans
les suites qui sont données à ces
enfants un renfort des moyens un renfort
financier une campagne de
sensibilisation une plateforme 119 pro
la réécriture des programmes d'éducation
à la vie affective et sexuelle le
maillage des aped il y a beaucoup de
choses dans ce plan un plan ambitieux à
la hauteur des enjeux nous l'avons dit
nous souhaitons que le travail de la
civise continue avec des modalités et
une feuille de route renouvelée et
centré sur certaines missions sur les
violences sexuelles nous présenterons le
détail avec Éric Dupont Moretti dans les
toutes prochaines semaines mais vous
avez rappelé la lutte contre les
violenceces sexuelles c'est l'affaire de
tous et de toutes y compris du secteur
associatif dont nous avons évidemment
besoin vous avez appelé mon attention
sur l'association Espace qui fait un
travail remarquable dans votre
territoire notamment en milieu scolaire
elle a été financée dans le cadre d'un
appel à projet en 2022 le nouveau plan
violence comprend de nouveaux
financements pour des appels à projets
ambitieux nous regardons ensemble si
l'association peut à nouveau recouvrer
des sommes pour conduire ses projets je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur le député oui madame
la ministre je connais les blessures
vécues en silence par un enfant loin du
regard des autres comme on dit je vis au
quotidien avec un garçon de 14 ans qui a
subi pendant des mois les violence
physique et psychologique de son propre
père mon but est de porter la voix de
ceux que l'on n'entend pas cette phrase
et de Madame Brigitte Macron elle a
raison nous devons porter la voix des
enfants victimes d'inceste ou de
violence n'attendez pas merci de
soutenir l'association Espace qui sauve
des enfants chaque jour merci beaucoup